the first curveball which i've already
warned you about is
even though our initial instinct for
several years has been to rationalize a
denominator
i'm going to make this denominator a bit
of a disaster but that's okay i can deal
with it okay
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
multiply through by
the square root of x plus 1 square root
of x plus 1. so here's how it's going to
look
you're going to get this on the
numerator
and then you're going to get this
on the denominator so fast we're good
try not to skip anything here
okay now the whole reason for this is
because now my numerator is going to be
rational
and my denominator is going to be the
square root of a
quadratic now even though that's messier
than what i had before
i can deal with it what do we got here
they it adds
to 8 and it multiplies to 7. that's my
pair my 1 and my 7.
okay and this of course is respect to
x now when you have a look at this right
oh yes question uh yeah i did mistakenly
write a minor seven
i meant to write it as a plus sorry
about that okay so i've got this
okay yes it is sorry
now sorry sorry you've already gone
through
and now i should point out that's that's
my bad that's on me
i should point out of course it's not
gonna be materially different you're
just going to get slightly
messier coefficients sorry yeah well in
in my defense
it's still kind of horrible anyway so
maybe it's not going to turn out that
much of an advantage
this is important though have a look at
this next moment right when you have a
look at this
there's a non-obvious thing to do
certainly when i first learned this
i was like why do they do that right
have a look
eyes up for a second that's my numerator
now i'm about to break it apart
i'm about to break apart this numerator
but i'm going to do it
in a way that when i first do it you'll
say
why would you do it that way here's how
i'm going to break up the numerator
i'm going to break up the numerator into
x plus 4.
and morgan morgan approves but thank
goodness morgan approves
everything is fine right and
i'm also gonna put in minus three okay
now
so some of you are looking at this and
saying yes of course of course
and the rest of you are like what the
like where did that come from
like maybe an x and a one maybe um
why why this awkward way of doing it now
you need to think you need to think
about where you're headed you need to
think about where you're going
right if you have a look at this
denominator this quadratic denominator
right
if you look carefully at it maybe some
of you will recognize
this is going to be related to using
reverse chain rule
right reverse chain rule because you've
got a quadratic here and then you've got
a linear
one up here so if there's going to be
some reverse chain rule and if this is
f if i call this f then i would like
f dash to appear somewhere i would like
f dash to appear
somewhere if this is f what's f dash
2x plus 8
maybe you want to jot this down as a
note for yourself right
if f dash of this f is 2x plus a
then if i can get something that looks
like 2x plus 8 in here
in this case it's just off by a constant
coefficient
then that's really good that's really
good for me right this is gonna walk
right into
my reverse chain rule okay over here
what am i gonna need to do
i'm gonna have to deal with it quite
separately actually this is not an f
dash on f situation what's gonna go on
yeah this is if you have a look at that
well i've gotten rid of it your fifth
throw down right
this thing here i want to complete the
square so i'm gonna have to deal with
these quite
separately let's have a go let's see how
far i get in three minutes
so to make it more obvious i'm going to
pull out a factor of a half
to get my 2x plus eight which i actually
want and then just to make it
just to have a few less things going on
in my brain i'm gonna write this
in index form what is the appropriate
index
negative half and q so that is with
respect to x can you see i've
set it up for reverse chain rule right
okay looking over here
like a whole separate question almost
right i've got my three at the top
and then here to complete the square
to get the right constant here yeah i'm
going to halve and square
half and square so in this case that's a
4
squared is 16. so i get x squared plus
8x
plus 16. there's my square minus 9
because what i actually have
is that seven over there so far so good
uh with respect to x okay are we ready
to do this bit
yeah you reckon yeah okay here we go so
this half
is separate to the integration okay
here's my f dash i've divided i have to
divide by f dash in the reverse
chain rule i've also got to increase the
power by one
so that leaves me with x squared plus
eight x plus
seven i've increased by one to the power
of half
and then what's the last step in reverse
chain rule
i it is times by two but for me i'd
prefer to because i always do this right
i divide by whatever my power was right
so i'm dividing by a half okay and of
course you can see what's about to
happen there that looks good
all right over here i'm not quite happy
i would like to do one more step before
i actually perform the integration
because i'm just skeptical my own brain
uh
yeah i'm going to leave that 3 there
what do we get so i've got the square
root of
x plus 4
squared minus 9 which is um
is it advantageous to me to write that
as 3 squared yeah i don't think it
this is a log isn't it this is a log
it's not really going to matter as much
okay
so let's see here my hearts are gone so
i get this
oopsy daisy i've actually been a bit
cheeky because i have broken apart these
lines so really there should be a
constant here
because i've only integrated one and not
the other
ah now let's deal with this okay so
what's going to happen to these three
hang out the front we can finish it
right and then
help me out log off
x squared x squared absolute value
okay okay hold on hold on hold on okay
i'm not gonna i'm not even gonna bother
hold on
here's one i prepared earlier okay there
you go all right
so now
now just as you finish writing that and
then pack up
um you can see part of the challenge of
this question
and i did this to myself sort of running
out of time right um
is just how how broad this question
becomes
this question becomes like four
questions worth of an advanced student's
integration right just out of that one
single
uh look i mean it started off look he
looks so harmless
right and then it's like you became this
right so be methodical be careful
you can see this one's not quite
finished i need another line there but